سوى ان نفوز هذه الحرب ليس فقط من اجل
امننا ولكن ايضا من اجل امن واستقرار
المنطقه وباقي العالم
الغربي السابع من اكتوبر سوف يبقى في
التاريخ
كمج فظيعه وكان هذا الهجوم الاسوا المعادي
لساميه منذ محركه اليهود مجزره السابع من
اكتوبر هي دعوه ليقض الع
باكمله والدعوه ليقض بوجه الارهاب ومعدات
الساميه ارهابي حماس قتلوا اكثر من 12 شخص
واحرقوا الاشخاص وهم احياء واعدموا المئات
من الرجال والنساء والشباب في المهرجان
الموسيقي واغتصبوا النساء واختطفوا اكثر
من 240 رهينه من بينهم اطفال ونساء
ومسنين احد هذه الرهائن ونحن موجودون هنا
اليوم نتكلم كفيل
بيبس ليس طفلا بل هو
رضيع عمره 11 شهرا هذه جريمه ضد
الانسانيه يجب ان يتم الافراج عن كل
الرهائن
الان كل يوم يمر يبقى هذا الواقع كابوسا
بالنسبه للعائلات وبالنسبه ل جميعنا نحن
ندعو المجتمع الدولي بان يقوم بكل ما هو
ممكن من اجل المساعده على الافراج عن كل
الاسرى في اسرع وقت ممكن لقد نجحنا في
الافراج عن 100 رهينه ولقد قمنا بعمليات
عسكريه مكثفه السبب الوحيد الذي دفع حماس
للقبول قبول الافراج عن الاسرى هو الضغط
العسكري لذلك الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار هي
خاطئه هي دعوه خاطئه اود ان اذكر المجتمع
الدولي بانه كان هناك وقف اطلاق النار في
السادس من اكتوبر ومن ثم حماس اخترقت هذا
هذه الوقفه بطريقه وحشيه اذا قمنا بوقف
اطلاق نار الان سوف تكون ذلك هديه لحماس
وهذا الامر لن يؤدي الى الافراج عن
الرهائن وسوف نعود الى الواقع
الذي كنا نعيش فيه في السادس من
اكتوبر منظمه حماس
الارهابيه احتفلت بقرار الجمعيه العامه في
الاسبوع الماضي التي دع الى وقف اطلاق
النار لا يجب ان يتم الاحتفال بذلك هذا ما
تريده حماس اود ان ارسل رساله واضحه
للمجتمع الدولي وللدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده اذا احتفلت منظمه ارهابيه بقراركم
هذا الامر يعني انكم
اقترفتموها
الحرب ضد حماس حتى نحقق ثلاثه اهداف اولا
القضاء على حماسه في قطاع غزه ثانيا
الافراج عن كل الرهائن
المحتجزين وثالثا تغيير الواقع في قطاع
غزه
بطريقه لن تكون هذه
المنطقه خطرا على اسرائيل في المستقبل
اليوم اكثر من 70 عاما اكثر من 70 يوما
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وخلال الاسابيع
العشره الماضيه يتعرض مواطنين للقصف من
قطاع غزه ولكن ليس فقط من قطاع غزه منذ
السابع من
اكتوبر حزب
الله وكيل ايران حاول ان يصعد الحرب على
الحدود الشماليه وتعرضنا ايضا لهجوم من
منظمه ارهابيه اخرى الحوثيين المدعومين من
ايران وهم يتلقون المسيرات والصواريخ على
السفن ايضا في البحر
الاحمر المنظمات المدعومه من النظام
الايراني هي المسؤوله عن هذه الهجمات
اسرائيل لا تريد ان تفتح جبهه جديده على
الحدود الشماليه لكن سوف نقوم بكل ما هو
واجب من اجل حمايه
مواطنينا هناك اكثر من 50 ال اسرائيليا
اجبروا على ترك منازلهم على مقربه من
الحدود مع لبنان علينا ان
نضمن امنهم لكي يتمكنوا من العوده الى
ديارهم الطريقه الوحيده لتحقيق ذلك هي من
خلال اجبار حزب على الانسحاب الى شمال نهر
الليطاني هناك طريقتين لتحقيق
ذلك اما من خلال الدبلوماسيه او من خلال
القوه مجلس الامن في الامم
المتحده اقر في العام 2006 بعد الحرب
القرار
171 هذا القرار يقر بوضوح بانه لا يجب ان
يكون هناك اي قوه عسكريه جنوب نهر
الليطاني سوى الجيش
اللبناني لا يزال هناك طريقه لتفادي الحرب
في لبنان
اذا لم ينجح المجتمع الدولي في القيام
بذلك لن يترك لنا سوى حلا واحدا وهو
القيام بذلك بانفسنا وخلال الاسابيع
الماضيه لقد تحدثنا مع بعضنا البعض عن بعض
الافكار المتعلقه بكيفيه حل هذا تحدي وكان
هناك ايضا محادثات فيما بين زملائنا بشان
هذه المساله انني اعتقد ان اصدقائنا
يمكنهم ان يؤدوا دورا مهما وايجابيا
لتفادي الحرب في لبنان حضره السيده كاترين
اود ان اشكرك مجددا على صداقتك ودعمك واود
ايضا ان اذكر الرساله المهمه
التي ارسلتها فيما يتعلق بالج
الرائم المروعه التي ارتكبت بحق النساء
الاسرائيليات الوكاله الامميه التي كان
عليها ان تتحدث عن هذه الجرائم كانت صامته
اليوم هناك محادثات مهمه وسوف نواصل العمل
مع بعضنا البعض من اجل مواجهه التحديات
التي هي موجوده امامنا اولا الافراج
الفوري عن كل الرهائن شكرا جزيلا شكرا
حضرا السيده tr